i'm going to do this i'm going to hire a
santa
i'm going to find a foot traffic area
and i'm going to make like 10 grand in a
day no way
there's no way you're going to be able
to pull this off
i bet you 500
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
should we be doing a like
we right now we just roll into the
conversation should we be doing a thing
where it's like this is the my family
podcast where we do xyz because like if
you're a new person coming on
the podcast starts with you being like
we good okay
so i want to tell you a story i bought a
car and the car has a transmission you
know what a transmission is so check
this out and then you're like you go
into the thing so should we be uh
educating people on what this is or you
think that's true try hard and just
no i think we should we we did
the intros at the end for a while where
we recorded them and put them in front
but
how do you i don't even know how to
describe this podcast when i meet
someone and they ask me what i do for a
living i say oh i do this thing i also
host this podcast called my first
million and i'm always embarrassed to
say the name but then what do you
explain the podcast is
yeah i would say like you know for
people who are
uh
they're kind of like business nerds or
they're they're idea junkies so they're
always you know scheming or wondering
you know what's the business behind this
how much money does this make how much
money does this person have those types
of questions that you're not allowed to
say out loud
this is the place where we talk about
those things out loud that's kind of my
my off top my head description and so we
brainstorm if you wanna you know if you
wanna sit here while we brainstorm
business ideas
and break down the economics behind
businesses that you've heard over never
heard of um
this is the podcast for you
great well there's our intro another way
another way i'd put it is every other
podcast you can listen to if you go into
itunes is gonna be
about the past or about the future and
we tell you something about the present
right now so
past is all interviews about you've
done the future is you know guessing
about you know what the world's gonna
look like in 20 years
and what we do is we talk about business
opportunities that exist today that uh
that you should be looking either
building investing in or just knowing
about but it's not just business for
example
i got messages sometimes we talk about
health related stuff or we just talk
about like things we're doing with our
life
and i got messages saying people love it
for example right now i'm staying at my
friend's house in hawaii
and i posted a video on my twitter did
you see that video looks sick okay it
looks sick but there's something
interesting about this house and what my
friend does that i think is amazing
so he only has one it's a really big
living room he's got a huge living room
he's got a very small couch the rest
he's got pads like pillows on the floor
and it's people it's floor sitting like
it's like a floor sitting scheme or like
a layout and i love it have you ever sat
like they do a house where people like
to sit on the floor
so my sister did this unintentionally so
my sister i think i think i've mentioned
i should probably talk about her
businesses because they're pretty cool
yeah
but she basically does uh something
called in home like in-home uh
daycare or preschool so she does both
and so like
she took she took over my apartment so
my parents were like hey my parents had
a house and attached to the house was a
two-bedroom condo and i was living in
that right when i moved to san francisco
i lived in that that place uh like for
like a year
and
then i got noticed i was getting evicted
by my parents i was like what's going on
it's like oh yeah your sister needs the
space she's starting a business in here
so like you know you got to get the
out and like she's going to take over
this space so where we had the living
room
she basically ran a preschool out of
that space
and uh
you told me the numbers it was a really
good business
oh it's still a great business so she
has three of these now uh they're
they're all different so she's got an
outdoor so it's even better right so
first so the first genius move was
instead of going in renting a commercial
space she's like oh i'll just use
like an in i'll do in home and okay why
is that good well you're already paying
the mortgage and what happens is from
you know 8 a.m to 4 p.m during the day
a part of your home will be used for
your preschool your daycare and now if
you're a student so you would think okay
yeah that seems pretty small like you
got what 10 kids in there no no big deal
well every kid pays three thousand
dollars so that's 30 grand a month of
income coming in
now
uh you have teachers so you got maybe
three teachers uh there
it ends up being about 40 40 i want to
say profit i i might be wrong ahead but
it's about 40 profit there's another
hidden benefit which is you can write
off pretty much everything about your
house and your in-home life because your
business runs out of your home so you
basically pay no taxes uh sorry your all
your life expenses are also business
expenses in a way uh because that couch
that you got or that mat that play mat
you bought that's all for the school
right all the toys you bought that your
kids also get to play with they're for
the school you're and she also sent her
kids to the school so her own
what she would normally be paying for
daycare now she was getting you know for
free because she had her own school
and so and then she started she created
an even better one which was an outdoor
only program so what's better than using
your in-home for for for your space no
space at all use the public parks and
this was great because a whole bunch of
parents didn't want their kids
indoors all day and like sitting you
know
kind of like sitting inside well you're
going to do that at home anyways why
don't you get out there like a good kid
and go play go go play with nature and
so she created nature kids which is this
program in san francisco and it's
actually awesome has like the highest
reviews and there's i went to the class
and basically all the other parents were
there and i was just kind of talking to
the parents
it's like oh yeah this guy he started uh
kiva this guy's ex paypal this guy is
it's like all these like billionaires of
san francisco basically sending their
kids to this outdoor program wait she
has three of them now
so she has yeah she has three total uh
programs so this could be like a like a
seven figure a year
business
yeah it is yeah so it is it is that and
and so and so she has like teachers who
who
you know run the day-to-day she's on
walkie-talkie with them like doing like
throughout the day and she has like nest
cameras in the place so she can be like
uh like hey you know like
you know where she can keep an eye on it
but she's not day-to-day involved
anymore which is great at the beginning
it was her and my mom was like making
the food for the kids like making tacos
and and like now it's all like you
know
all done done and and they're home
they're they're floor sitters
so okay yeah so back to the floor
setting thing sorry so
because of that whenever i go to my
sister's place
um her living room there was no
furniture there was no tv there was no
nothing like a normal living room would
have she had done like what you did with
your home gym she had just turned the
whole floor into play mats and even
better than just the floor sitting
because it's just play mats and then
like
all the walls had like kind of like kids
games and decals and stuff like that but
then she had these like little swings
for kids like you know you know like a
rope swing like tarzan just like hanging
from the middle of the room so like
things that would occupy the kids but
then when i would go hang out there i'm
floor sitting i'm just like stretching
while we're hanging out with you
that's exactly what i'm doing so so i
was getting so limber just like
hanging out with my sister because why
wouldn't i just be stretching and
rolling and just getting to know my body
a little bit and then there's a swing
there so now i'm kind of like practicing
rope climbs like a fireman and and
i was like dude this is like
i don't know what like it's like an
ergonomic lifestyle it's like you know
there's this
whole my lifestyle just changed into
this like mobile tarzan you know one
with nature and one with my body that's
exactly what i got
every time i'm here so he's got this
like hammock swing coming down from the
ceiling and so you have to like sit in a
particular way where you're stretching
and then he's got like these cushions
that are only like eight inches above
the ground yeah and you just sit there
and it takes a minute to get used to it
it is so much better than sitting on a
couch it's so much better it's the best
i watched this youtube video recently
and this guy had this whole like theory
it was like it's kind of like a ted talk
this guy's got this video and it's all
about how like sitting is like crushing
us and basically his whole thing is
basically that you should stand most of
the time and you should stand in a very
particular way where you like squeeze
your butt and so it's like your hips are
directly underneath you and he's got
this whole talk and he like looks at
these people who don't sit in normal 90
degree chairs and he shows like what
their butt looks like and it's like the
whatever it's like the whole point is he
like has all these visuals anyway i've
been floor sitting and it is awesome i'm
100 gonna stick with this or at least
i'm going to try to
yeah it's a total hack i should do that
uh like i do love me some couch time but
i definitely want to have a room
that's just pure maths and then when i
hang out there work there just roll
around there it's just like a different
vibe and with kids it's perfect because
that's what they naturally want anyways
and so i'm just going to do that with my
giant like playroom do you want to talk
about um ozzy
this is amazing i got a bunch of topics
i'm going to save half of them for next
time but we'll do half today
um
this is an amazing amazing story
the story came out about aussie media
and if you missed it i'm going to give
you the rundown and then i want sam i
want you to react yeah i know all about
it
okay so here's what i know and you fill
in the gaps okay so i heard about this
because
uh the story breaks in the new york
times and they basically say
and they talk about aussie media a
company that i never really heard of
most people have no idea what it is
red flag number one so they go
they were it's a company that's raised
150 million dollars
and they were on this call with goldman
sachs and goldman sachs is ready to
invest 40 million dollars in the company
and they're just sort of doing their
final kind of like diligent slash get to
know you calls
and they're one of the selling points
that ozzy was telling goldman sachs
about like how it's defensible and how
we're like this next gen media company
was they were like
our youtube videos which you see you
know some of our youtube videos get
millions of views
which is good for news and media company
um it's you know youtube loves us the
data shows that you know youtube sees
that you know gen z or millennials like
love our content so they're big fans of
our of our content we're going to be
doing much more with youtube so you know
your investment now you're investing in
this like next-gen video company as well
and so they they get on a call they're
like why don't we do a call with us the
founders of ozzie goldman and uh the
executive over at youtube who runs
youtube originals and so
they get on the call and they're on a
conference call and they're waiting for
the the youtube guy emails and says hey
i'm running a few minutes late sorry and
so they're on this video call and then
the youtube guy says hey guys i'm you
know i'm sorry i'm still stuck in
traffic can't do video can we just
switch to a uh a phone call conference
call sorry for the inconvenience and
everyone's like no problem we switch
over to the phone call
and he calls in and he says hey i'm so
inside let's call him jeff i don't know
what his name is i'm jeff from youtube
yeah ozzy is amazing our data shows that
it just crushes other media companies uh
they're really innovative we plan to
feature them and do a whole lot more
it's so great and the goldman guys
they're like wow that sounds good but
you know they sort of noticed like
his voice sounded a little funny almost
like it was like a like a voice changer
and they're like ah that's probably
nothing
but you know like just in case let's go
ahead and just like double check in our
diligence here let's just let's just
email the guy from youtube and just just
make sure you know it's all all good and
they were like oh you know he had
emailed us from a gmail which is kind of
weird you know like the official jeff at
gmail.com like let's just email let's
just go to youtube themselves and just
email him directly
and so they email and that guy of course
is like
what the hell i've never heard of aussie
media no i was not on a phone call what
are you talking about
and so goldman's like what the is
going on and so this basically was and
then they they they go back to the
company and the company's like oh my god
yes we're so sorry i'm a lapse in
judgment we had that was my co-founder
on the call you know like we're
embarrassed
sorry that was just a bad bad decision
i don't know i don't even know how they
could with a straight face back out of
that but they you know they back out of
it and goldman says okay look we're not
gonna invest because obviously
shady as but uh you know we're not
gonna make a big deal out of it so you
know whatever so they back out
and this this company if you look into
aussie they had made some pretty big
claims so those are some other big
claims so
50 million monthly uniques they said
their email newsletter had 20 million
monthly subscribers which is like
you know as somebody who has like the
biggest thing ever yeah yeah so it would
be unheard of
i think the public numbers morning
brewers said they had three million i
think you guys are right around that
same number so to to do you know 10
times more than that would be like wow
that's pretty substantial like that's
interesting
and uh oh you have 50 million uniques
like on your website when i go there it
looks like you have less than a million
according to this
50 million monthly uniques is also like
a top
100 or top 200 website i mean it's it's
huge
so people start looking into it and they
start looking into all their claims so
they claim they're like we are amazon
prime's first talk show
and then you go look into it it's like
they used it wasn't like amazon prime
commissioned and paid them for a talk
show they used something called like
direct upload which just lets anybody
upload their thing into the library
and uh and then they claimed that they
were the first and then they were using
amazon's name and all their like kind of
like billboards and ads saying it was
amazon's first and amazon sent them a
cease and desist and was like take our
name off your and uh and he's like
i stand by our claims but you know of
course we'll take your name off this and
um and then they claim that they are the
fastest growing talk show on youtube and
the journalist was like
so how do you know that because you know
we talked to social blade they measured
this kind of thing they said you're
pretty like average
he's like well you know we're the
fastest growing premium talk show that's
youtube centric like their own category
they made up and we looked and we
couldn't find a faster growing one and
it's like oh so you looked and you
couldn't find one and so you said you
are the best one and then they look if
you look at their youtube videos they'll
have like a million views but like less
than 100 comments so
you know a little fishy a little fishy
you know what's going on here and so um
and by the way they had like pretty
legit investors so axel springer
uh mark lazary who owns the milwaukee
bucks like steve jobs wife david
drummond who's just like you know long
time google exec uh they had some pretty
like legit investors still have pretty
legit investors and the funny thing is
after goldman sachs walked away and all
this happened they still raised money
always still raised another round and so
what's your what what did i miss and
what's your reaction yeah so the
takeaway here is twofold the first is we
actually talked about this a few weeks a
week or two ago we said that you can
raise a fair amount of money and pretty
much lie and most people will not check
in on you
right yeah
we said we said the following
i'm surprised more people ain't lying
because it would be so easy and quite
lucrative to do so yeah when it comes to
the thing and we said
most people us included don't do a ton
of diligence and even if you do
it's very easy to get away with the
basic diligence and we're nobodies right
we're we're doing this and then you take
these larger funds larger names
and uh they still don't do it they all
got duped too you know what i mean so
it's like uh so
there is a systemic problem in a way
it's a feature and a problem the feature
is this industry runs on trust and the
reason you you and i can do deals on a
handshake is because we trust each other
and we and there's a lot of founders out
there who are but the majority of people
are not trying are not duplicitous or
lying or committing fraud and so that's
why silicon valley can move at a fast
pace because we don't have to take three
to six months to diligence every single
deal we do that's why we can move at a
fast pace but the flip side of that is
it does create an opportunity for
fraudsters to to lie which doesn't
happen often but so basically i believe
the founder's name is carlos watson and
carlos watson is a very charismatic guy
i think he was a host or had a tv show
or something like that on both pbs and
cnn if i remember correctly they started
about a year or two before us and i
remember i recruited people from there
or and i had one woman who worked there
who have worked for us and and i would
ask them about it uh ask her about them
and basically they caught my eye because
i would use similar web and i would
notice that they had very little traffic
and if you go to on their website now
the hustle probably actually gets more
traffic than they do and we don't even i
compared you guys have about 10 more
traffic according to that than them yeah
we don't even try to get traffic like we
don't like that's not our business is
not web traffic but their business is
web traffic aussie additionally their
website is horrible like it's one of
these sites that looks pretty but you go
to it and you're like how the hell do
you work this thing and like it's like
impossible to figure out what they're
like as a marketer and an entrepreneur i
can go to a website and i can look at
i'm like oh the goal is to drive me to
this thing when i see their thing i'm
like what are they trying to get me to
do and so i've always had a red flag
about this company because they claimed
these huge valuations they claimed these
this huge reach and i don't know anyone
who consumed it i when i was in new york
i used to see um
buses with their logos on it and they're
buying all these ads and media companies
don't buy ads media companies sell ads
and you're not buying a bus ad of all
ads and so i used to see this and i knew
that something weird was happening
because it didn't make sense how they
made money and they constantly had to
raise money and so this was always full
of to me um i'm a little surprised
axel springer invested in it because
they're pretty legit but i'm not
surprised that steve jobs wife invested
into it because she invests in a lot of
non-profit making stuff so i'm like well
she just gives money to anyone um but
yeah this company i think is nonsense
they also claim that they have these
huge festivals and i've never heard of
anyone that went to one of their
festivals so i've always thought that
this company was full of it and now
there's some proof
yeah yeah funny i mean it's crazy how
this stuff goes down and then you see
people who are so there's one i think
mark lazary's on the board and i think
he was i think they released a statement
like oh you know
we you know a lapse in judgment we we we
stand by this kind of temporary
momentary kind of like lapse in judgment
uh you know they're making the right
steps to correct this
um i don't even think the co-founders
like got fired i think i think he's
still there i'm correct dude it's a
weirdos company and they also claim that
they're you know where they they say
they're based out of is palo alto
and like you and i have lived here for
for 10 15. never heard of them never met
a single employee yeah never met anybody
who reads them or shared an article from
them uh also not where you would start a
media company is palo alto so you know
just strange all around yeah so that's
weird um
do you want can i tell you about a uh
can i can i do one real quick okay so
have i ever told you about um
uh newspapers.com
you told me about this and i remember
going to it be like oh i've never been
to like that sounds like a very common
word and i remember going to it you said
it was something cool but but say it
again okay for me because i don't
remember in another so i believe it was
owned by ancestry.com and so
ancestry.com it's a website where you
can do two things you can enter in your
dna
or
you can enter in your last name like you
give them your dna and they you know do
23 me and they tell you who you're
related to or you just do um you enter
in your name and you could track like
you know if you came into ellis island
and like who your great-grandparents
were based off of civil war records and
all this weird stuff
and they owned they bought this
archive called newspapers.com and it
scans every newspaper they could
possibly get a hold of and you could
search it
and i use it for research all the time
and if you scroll down on our doc sean i
actually gave you an example
so dan gilbert started this company
called quicken loans he owns the
cleveland cavaliers is that what he owns
yeah and he's like a big shot detroit
whatever
and he seems like a nice guy and i was
curious about his background and so i
used newspapers.com to learn about his
company so quicken loans originally was
called rock financial and i sent you
three examples of why newspapers.com is
incredibly fascinating the first you can
read profiles about people so quicken
loans went public i think in 1997 i
found an article
from 1996 i think and you could read
that article and it's a profile on dan
and he'll explain
they'll say dan gilbert's off office is
really funny he's got toys everywhere
and he'll say well my you know what i'm
trying to do is build this fun work
plate you know whatever and so you see
like first-hand knowledge as they are
building about how their philosophy on
business and that's incredibly
fascinating and he'll also say like yeah
you know we started the business with
five thousand dollars of savings and
then we scaled to this much revenue and
so you could actually see in real time
how they're describing the business and
where they came from the second thing
that you can do and i do this all the
time is i find their ads in classified
newspapers
where they
list jobs so i actually listed one of
their their job ads so how would you do
this so let's say you're wanting to find
this can you search like everywhere rock
financials mentioned or you had to
literally go just let me check this
sunday and check the job section and see
if there's no so what i did was i typed
in rock financial
i typed in show me all the newspapers
within a radius of detroit because i
knew that's where they're based out of
and then i said uh make it between 1995
and 1996.
and then pay for newspapers.com this is
a paid service 10 a month um and when i
and then i i could see it says when
you're searching it says which newspaper
it's from and which section of the
newspaper and who the author is so i can
very quickly see if this is a profile if
this is like just dan gilbert giving a
quote on the economy or if this is a job
ad and i read the job ads job ads are
actually amazing so if you ever want to
see what a company's launching even
today you go to their website and you
click jobs and if you see like oh wow
youtube is hiring or i don't know i'm
making this up apple is hiring people
who have experience in cars amazing
they're clearly like going into like so
that's like a no-brainer but it's cool
to see uh and also on a lot of job uh
boards or websites they'll say you know
we're aussie media we reach 20 million
people a month we we cover this stuff
and so you see like it'll actually tell
you a lot of uh stats about the company
they have to they have to um
they have to sell themselves right if
you're recruiting people and by the way
super super sneaky move
go interview at a competitor's company
to find out their
their data because during the interview
process you'll find out a lot about the
company's strategy about their numbers
things like that and that's one way to
get competitive intel that i've i've
heard some people do or you can recruit
the people who work there knowing that
you're not going to hire them that's
another one well that one is a little
bit harder because you recruit somebody
and you put them in a position and some
people get really some people are like
oh yeah like happy to share nothing
nothing that was confidential but just
you know here's my point of view on what
i think they care about and what they're
roughly the size of the of this of this
part of their business but then some
people are like i can't believe you're
asking me to divulge information about
my previous sure yeah you have to be
respectful you got to go about it in a
certain way so anyway newspapers.com i
use it to look at job ads and i can see
like how they describe their company
back then and like what they were
recruiting for sometimes you could see
salary and so it actually adds a lot of
context around it and then finally i
look at ads that they use to get
customers and so you can see like how
they describe themselves how they got
customers uh things like that you can
see if you look at job ads you can see
how they're structuring their business
it's actually an amazing tool and so the
difference is is that when you read
biographies they'll tell you like a
third person point of view on like
analyzing it when i do this when i do it
this way i'm like well here's exactly
how they describe themselves and um like
yeah it's different because it's moment
in time versus
hindsight right biography is always
hindsight now that we've seen it all
play out we can connect the dots
in this way
but when you just go back to the source
material at that time when it went to
print
this is how it was seen in the moment
which is which is really useful because
like i've done this with tech companies
you can go read when twitter launched on
techcrunch and it's a small blurb yeah
it's like oh this goofy thing called
twitter launch it's kind of buzzy at
this party but it kind of has no point
i'm keeping an eye on it blah blah it's
like oh pretty inconspicuous launch for
something i guess that became as
influential as twitter you could go see
this for you can go see their original
landing pages and their original launch
press and how they position themselves
you can go read original like launch
announcements on hacker news for dropbox
and other things you can go see the the
five minute video that drew houston put
up demoing dropbox and the comments of
people being like dude no one needs this
and um you know here we are you know
20 billion dollars
and for the modern stuff like a dropbox
and twitter there's two ways you do that
the first is when you search on google
you there's right underneath this uh the
text bar you go all the way to the right
and you click search tools and you could
change the date so you change the date
and so you make it so if let's say
twitter launched in 2009 you type in
twitter and you take out the e because
that's how you remember they spelled it
and you do like year 2005 to 2010 i
forget when they first launched and you
actually see it or you go to
webarchive.com
and or waybackmachine.com i forget just
google one of those and then you can
actually see the early landing pages so
anyway that's a cool hack that i wanted
to show you about um
it's pretty amazing
by the way this print ad i just want to
re i just put it in my swipe file but
like this ad for them they go it says
everybody's talking mortgage first and
then there's a quote from a customer we
found out that the bank's pre-approval
is just a piece of paper with mortgage
first we got a firm commitment and
locked in a low rate there's no easier
way to shop for home right that's like
the print ad headline and it's just cool
to see the copywriting of these like
these types of products you know it's
not it's not the sexiest type of product
to send to sell as you know a mortgage
and that's exactly my point
so here's the point when you're starting
something you say to yourself i want to
be like quicken loans or i want to be
like let's say you have a clothing
company i want to be like louis vuitton
i want to be like gucci and you have to
i want to be like steve jobs and apple
and you have to remember
that it's always on nine out of 10 times
it's not glamorous early on and so you
can go and look at early apple products
and you're like oh wow they're they were
just like i am like they were still
trying to figure out they weren't that
great and what they said
then
like i can't connect
like it's hard to imagine that this
thing became this end thing right that
this early ad or this early profile like
i never would have guessed that
therefore
if you go to rocketmortgage.com now
and it's like you know this diverse crew
of like white black asian people sitting
on beautiful couches and it says rocket
mortgage is the home loan experience
designed for you you're one of a kind
your mortgage should be too start an
application to see what's possible right
like a very different type of ad and so
if you wanted to be the next them don't
copy what they say now now that they
have kind of branded and they have a
sales force all these other things go
copy what they did at the beginning when
they had zero brand awareness and they
had to like explain what they do quickly
to people in a more literal sense rather
than these like kind of like fancy
marketing brochures
exactly that's exactly my point and so i
think this is incredibly helpful tool
both intellectually because you can get
ideas but also emotionally and you can
see that like oh wow they weren't always
like kick ass they sucked like me
or you know they were only okay or i
never would have predicted that they
ended where they start based off where
they started
right okay i got i got one for you can
we switch yeah which one you're going to
do you got a lot of really good ones
i'm going to give you my blue collar
side hustle okay so uh so this is this
is the blue collar side hustle segment
for for this week which is basically
a way you can make money not a ton but
like
thousands or tens of thousands of
dollars maybe a hundred thousand dollars
um with just a little bit of sweat and
creativity that's the blue collar side
also okay so what is it
so it's we're
we're about to start october
and this last quarter of the year is
holiday season it's the biggest shopping
season of the year people are ready to
spend
and coming into the holidays there's one
little side hustle that i always thought
was interesting and i started looking
into it and it's this business of
mall santas so have you ever like have
you ever done this you don't have like a
little kid so you may not have ever done
this but like
last two years since my daughter was
born
you know come christmas season uh sonya
always wants to like go to the go to see
the santa and have us take a family
photo with the santa for like the
memories with our like baby sits in
santa's lap take a photo dude
which is when you think about it
weird that is it's so weird
like
why does like this young couple who like
if you're an immigrant or you're like in
your case you're idiot like just believe
that
you gotta get this picture with this fat
old white dude
oh by the way barely looks like santa
right so the one i'm going to and also
kid
cries 100 of the time right because you
put them in a stranger's a stranger who
looks like a monster's lap surrounding
you like dwarves they're surrounded by
dwarves and other strangers looking at
you yeah you're like give me a smile and
they're like nah i'm crying here so um
okay so this little business so what is
this so let me just tell you how the
current system works and then what you
can do
so a mall santa will make between 10 and
25 000. in about a five-week sprint here
and all they do is they go they they buy
the outfit for about 300
and then they get hired by these like
photo companies like there's one company
called iconic that does this iconic what
they do is they pay they hire all these
mall santas and they have 300 malls in
america that they're partnered with and
then like a hundred like babies r us no
and they'll be like hey i need them i
need a santa and charleston you're gonna
make you know you're gonna make twenty
thousand dollars over the next five
seconds like a model agency for fat
white guys
exactly so then they send you they
dispatch you you just go sit there on a
chair for like six hours straight and uh
kid gets in your lap you say oh ho ho
what do you want for christmas take a
picture see you later and you just do
that it takes zero what do they use them
for the rest of the years like a
diabetes commercial like what are you
going to do with these guys
so let me tell you so okay so so that's
the first part so then uh so they have
about 6 000
santas that they hire just themselves
they showed that they get into the malls
and get prime real estate because they
showed the malls that having a santa
there will drive about a million in
incremental revenue because you get
increased foot traffic into the mall
because families like us come to the
mall to get the photo done with the
santa and you're paying like 50 bucks
per photo and you're doing a photo you
know every
i don't know minute and so like you can
just add up the cost per hour that other
sort of revenue per hour that iconic or
the person hosting this is doing
so i thought this was kind of cool then
i was like where do these people come
from
and basically there's been a spin-off
cottage industry
of santa training and santa out costume
like businesses
so there's like santa costume business
little e-commerce pop-ups like you know
halloween pop-ups so it's just selling
certain part of the year and it's the
boots and the glasses and the beards and
the hats and the robes and all that good
stuff so you'll end up spending hundreds
of dollars just to have one of these
outfits um i i own one of these outfits
because we wanted our at-home photos to
also have me in the santa outfit so you
know brown santa sitting next to the
tree i have a bunch of photos like that
from last year dude your wife is is
amazing this is all her instagram she's
like an instagram mom basically without
the followers so we all of the work of
being at instagram without any of the uh
influencer money that we get we should
be getting out of it so um so
so she does she really cares about
photos and so like she wants her
memories and she wants cute photos so i
have to do all this so okay so
then what happens so there's these
schools
that will charge you up to a thousand
dollars for santa training and what does
that mean it's like tells you what to
say it tells you how to groom your beard
and your hair to look like nick and then
helps you get a job as a as a santa
somewhere so that's like a whole little
cottage interesting now what do i think
you could do with this so i think this
can be done in a whole bunch of
different ways so i think you could kind
of independently do this in your
neighborhood so we've talked about like
how do you do um door-to-door in
neighborhoods so i think you could go
door-to-door in any neighborhood and say
hey tomorrow santa's gonna be here if
you want a christmas photo just come to
the front of the neighborhood buy that
tree and you're like mixing up a throne
this is like a pedophile's dream like
santa meets ice cream man
this is weird
it's not just the kid that does the
parents go with you to the thing it's
incredibly safe safer than a lemonade
stand my friend so this is the lemonade
stand we do in the winter which is you
do a pop-up santa photo photo thing and
if you were going door-to-door you could
go door-to-door dressed as the elves
saying that santa's coming all right so
that's that's one way of doing this the
other is you can partner with really any
place that has foot traffic so whether
it's a mall
or it's kind of like an outdoor eating
area it's a farmer's market it's um you
know like you just need to find foot
traffic and if you pop yourself down my
estimate is that you're going to be able
to make
per minute doing this thing uh that
might be a little high let's just say 30
per minute because people don't always
opt for the big photo pack so thirty
dollars a minute add an hourly rate bro
okay so hourly that's 1800 an hour
and you're going to be there for let's
say six hours that's 10 grand a day you
can print doing this thing and all your
costs are you know fat santa for uh you
know hopefully that's somebody that's
you or somebody you know that you can
get to do it you buy me out for 400
another thousand dollars of props and
decorations and the chair and all that
stuff the photographer might cost you
let's call it a thousand dollars for the
day
and um and so that's your that's sort of
your cost structure going into this i
think the rest of it is pretty much free
because who's going to really kick out
santa
who uh who's iconic
iconic is the company that does like
like photo experiences and stuff like
that are they big
i think they're big because this isn't
their main business um
so i think this is like you know part of
their business if someone okay so i
agree with you that someone could pull
this off
i would be i'm just saying you want to
make 20 grand for the holiday season
that's nice a lot of people want 20
grand i would be amazed if someone is
well you got to have so much courage in
order to pull something like that off
that scares me this scares me but why
what scares you about this so it's kind
of like whenever i think of business
ideas i'm like anything that involves
eating something i'm like ugh that's so
that's all you got like it's like a big
burden right it's like a big burden uh
if you like if your product is going to
be eaten
oh you mean selling something other
people are going to eat yeah i'm like
well you can't that right you
got to like you got to nail that right
away and then like a tear down i'm like
well anything involving children i'm
like oh my god like you got to nail that
too you can't have anything weird going
on there's no risk here it's literally a
santa with the parents standing right
there next to you and you sit on their
knee for one second to take a photo it's
so real low risk it's not like a daycare
or something like that
daycare is up there too i mean this is i
would be i would be very curious if
anyone's going to pull this off this
isn't like you're just going to the
street and like break dancing like
you're going in the street and like
having a kid sit on your knee i just
think that uh dude i'm gonna i'm gonna
do this for the uh for my for you know
we were talking about our youtube
channel doing some uh some little
business stunts i'm gonna do this as one
of them this holiday season i'm gonna do
this i'm gonna hire a santa
i'm gonna find a foot traffic area and
i'm gonna make like 10 grand in a day no
way
there's no way you're gonna be able to
pull this off i bet you five hundred
dollars
there five hundred dollars okay what
part are you doubting okay maybe the 10
grand a day is the ambitious part no
maybe it's five okay i'll be very
curious to see if you can pull this off
this would be amazing
what do you think is going to happen
what do you think all the risk is
there's no risk i don't think there's
that much risk i just think there's a
huge amount of fear that i have about
doing this about anything involving the
risk is
sean gets lazy and doesn't decides not
to do it that's the only risk that's the
only thing preventing me from
successfully doing this
well
let's see
if i was you if i was white i wouldn't
even i would be saving myself the the
thousand dollars i'm gonna have to pay
some santa here to do this because
nobody i i nobody wants me to be the
santa so you know i'm already working
from a district are there ever black
santas that is kind of interesting we
gotta we gotta like what are there ever
i've never seen a non-white santa at a
mall
i'm sure i'm sure there is but uh yeah
maybe that's the underserved market that
i need to go for i think people want the
classics i think with holidays people
throw all the equality out the window
and they want the classes wait do you
do celebrate what religion are you are
you anything
i'm not religious but i do celebrate fun
days like christmas
yeah i didn't but you know i know you're
not religious like in terms of like a
god but like a culture like you know i'm
catholic i was raised catholic but do
you do you do anything
oh no i celebrate all the fun holidays
if any yeah oh dia de los muertos sounds
great i'm i'm you know i i'm hispanic
for the day well let's do that like any
any
any culture has a fun holiday i'll play
why not
i'm looking for more days to celebrate
yeah we gotta uh
yeah once i started like meeting my
jewish friends i started celebrating
shabbat so uh we could pick some
holidays
i love shabbat
give me some worship
yeah it's really good what do you want
to do this royalty-free music one i
think this is amazing
yeah okay so here's the idea so i saw
this on product hunt
i
kind of forgot the name but there was
basically a product that launched
yesterday or today and it's a
ai generated royalty-free music okay so
for anybody who's ever had to make a
commercial or like create a video or
you're an agency or a freelancer
music makes your video like 10 times
better but it sucks to have
all the music you know is copyright
protected so you'll put it up on youtube
it'll get muted or taken down or dmca
noticed and if you want to use it to
sell products or promote your company
you really can't do it it's illegal if
you use copyright music because you
don't have the permissions and so
there's this whole like genre of
royalty-free music out there and there's
all these big um
websites like pond5 that exist that will
give you royalty-free you know either
stock footage stock photos or stock
music
and this whole like stock industry is
pretty big
and so what i thought was cool here is
take a business like pond5 so i don't
know if you've ever used pond5 do you
know pawn five no no no no no no no no
no no no
so many times in my life it's great it's
like the best place to go if you want
like uh stock music for a thing is it
free and so how does it work
no you pay you end up buying the the the
music you like like while you're
listening to the sample it'll be like
the really good music and it'll be like
pond5 in the background like just like
as a watermark like every two seconds so
that you can't steal the thing you have
to buy it so
here's how i know this company crushes
they raised one round of funding
in 2014 it was a 60 million dollar round
which means they already had a bunch of
traction before then
since 2014 they haven't reported any
other raising of money and i know
they're still going super strong so
that's like you can sniff that and be
like what's the opposite of aussie media
it's this it's a company that raises one
mega round doesn't raise again for the
next seven years probably means it's
super profitable just spitting off cash
and they probably sold who they raised
61 million dollars from they probably
like it was probably they just sold a
bunch of their shares
yeah it's probably to get some liquidity
because i think they started in 2005 or
2008 or something like that so it was
like many years into the business that
they did around nerd wallet same thing
right they started they ended up raising
a hundred million dollars
never touched the hundred million
dollars like their bank account's never
been less than a hundred million dollars
since then it's like these are companies
that are lean mean and just super
profitable we should talk about nerd
wallet do you have intel and nerd wallet
uh you probably have more you're buddies
with the guy so i don't have much
but we should have him on i i was
talking to uh his his partner and he was
saying that he was saying oh yeah you
should have one and i thought that's a
good idea well he uh i heard they were
considering going public or something
like that and so he couldn't talk too
much but if i don't know if that's the
case anymore or not but
we uh you know when you're about to go
public you can't say too much and so
it's hard to get they're not good
interviews
well i can tell one uh
anecdote i heard which is just on how
they kind of got chartered how they made
it work so
early on with nerdwallet what nerdwell
it does is it's a blog for like kind of
like personal finance so it just kind of
gives you information you need to know
about about managing your own finances
and their money maker is that they rank
really high for credit card suggestions
so if you say what credit card should i
get nerd wallet's like at the top of the
list and then they'll break down in a
pretty objective way
here's you know the best credit cards
depending on your goals depending on who
you are
pick this one it's basically
nerdwallet.com
best dash credit dash card that page i
think that page likely makes like 80 of
the revenue and the entire company
exists to make sure that page shows up
number one on google when you search
best credit card
right exactly and i think
when we say 80 of the revenue i don't
know the revenue if i was guessing i
would guess that the revenue is 100
million dollars or more plus or minus 50
yeah um definitely not minus 50
okay so maybe plus 50 so so that's
pretty impressive right because when
when somebody clicks that link to go buy
it they they get an affiliate uh
kickback and so they'll get i don't know
what it is like two thousand dollars
it's like very lucrative to refer a
credit card 2500 or something like that
for a credit card referral so they make
a lot per customer that hits that page
so early on
all the sides so because that incentive
is so big every website in the early web
web days was just like who's going to
give me the highest kickback
fantastic you are my my recommended my
recommended card and so it was kind of
like it wasn't objective right they were
just there they were in the pocket of
the credit card companies and they were
just
printing you know shitty content to try
to get you to click that link um to go
through this which is which is how
red ventures started red ventures is a
company that makes north of a billion
dollars a year they basically started
doing that with both credit cards and
dish tv
right right yeah satellite tv and so so
with these like high high margin high
subscription products you know they'll
pay a lot for affiliates so
what nerdwallet was doing was they were
just two dudes sitting in their room
and they would just write blogs like
high quality blogs they're like we're
gonna write higher quality stuff because
these other ones are just kind of
content forms trying to generate clicks
and year after year they were just like
writing these things and it really
wasn't going very far it was like
not that impressive now you tell me if
i'm wrong on any of this uh it wasn't
really it wasn't taking off
it took just two basically in the first
two years there was i don't think there
was a month where they got more than a
thousand people visiting their website
and if you google
nerdwall hustlecon you'll see a talk
where he shows their traffic like it was
like
you know it was a shitty it was horrible
multiple years of staying the course
even when the evidence all said this
doesn't work because they trusted their
gut and their belief system that
if we put the highest content out
highest quality content out there
eventually we will get the traffic
and if we build it they will come and it
actually worked right so like you know
there is a counterpoint to every uh
every piece of advice i would if there
was if they were a startup doing this
right now i'd be like guys
two years no traffic less than 10 grand
a month you're making you how long have
you been in this apartment when's the
last time you left this building uh guys
like
look at this company they're just
shilling out shitty content and getting
way more traffic and paying for it and
just trying to arbitrage like do that
that's gonna work that's working so like
do that so my advice would have been
horrible here because this was a
tortoise-in-the-hair startup story that
actually worked and so
finally there's a google update uh
google updates a search engine and it
punishes the low quality blogs that were
out there and nerd wallet jumps in the
rankings and so all of a sudden they
they go from making you know zero
dollars a day to like seven grand a day
of revenue and that's from the the
traffic that's coming here and then a
few months later there's another update
and it goes to like 70 grand a day and
uh and they sort of never look back
they've always been kind of like near
the top or at the top for this kind of
thing uh since then so that that i
thought was pretty remarkable and you
know
i could have had that same idea i would
have never stuck to it uh the way that
those guys did and they deserve every
dollar they make off this yeah it's a
it's a pretty monster company um
what but what about pond5
okay so back to pond5 so pond5 my
research tells you this is quite a big
company they at one point they reported
60 million a year in revenue that was
like 10 years ago so wait a minute i'm
pretty sure that yeah so i'm pretty sure
that they're doing 100 million dollars
or north of 100 million dollars off this
most stock websites will do
you know 100 million dollar plus but
they get consolidated so like you know i
stock photo and all those things they
all get owned by the same company so
anyways what's the idea here well pond5
they have their value because they have
a big library so that when you're
searching for upbeat energetic music for
my commercial that's 60 seconds long
that doesn't sound cheesy i gotta find
that that that thing on your website and
so how do they get this library where
they don't make it themselves they let
any creator just like a stock photo site
you upload your content and then if
someone buys your thing you get a rev
share you get 50 rev share well here's
the cool thing about what's happened
like there's been a change where ai has
gotten a lot better and you can
auto auto-generate music now and so what
this product was doing was
you put your video in and it knows okay
your video is one minute and 23 seconds
long so that's how much music you need
and it can even look at in you know in
the future it can even look at you can
mark maybe key markers on your video you
say this is where the the climax happens
or where my product reveal happens like
i need a beat to like i need to i need
an uptick here right and then it will
auto generate an infinite number of
music amount of music for that that's
custom fitted to your video track
and you can just say i want it to be
playful i want it to be energetic i want
it to be serious i wanted to be
foreboding i wanted to be mysterious
and um and then you just hit generate
it'll give you one you say next next
next just like tinder you can swipe
through
and they're going to keep 100 of the
revenue so whatever whoever does this i
think they're going to have the biggest
library
pretty much from day 10 because their
neural net will have generated such a
vast amount of stock footage or stock
stock music or stock photos so i think
they're going to crush the existing
stock stock sites because they're going
to have 100 times more content and then
they're going to crush it in terms of
economics because they're not going to
have to share any of it with any content
creator and they're going to keep 100 of
it so i would love to invest in one of
these companies that's doing this that's
got the right marketing mojo to get this
out there because the fundamentals tell
me that however big istock photo and
those guys are the ai version of it is
going to be you know maybe four or five
times bigger and those today are like
multi-billion dollar companies i'd
imagine though the key to this business
is not the ai generated music part
i would imagine the difficult part here
is getting customers because the
um
stock photos and stock video and stock
music in terms of search traffic it's
impossibly challenging like it's it's
like oh i bet you it's almost as hard as
uh
credit cards like best credit card right
so that would be the hard part is how to
get customers you know a business is
basically like three things it's like
convincing people to work i guess
there's four things convincing people to
work there convincing someone to give
you money or figuring out how to get
capital to do it making the product and
then getting the sale this one falls
into that fourth bucket where that's the
hard part i would imagine is getting
people to go to your website
consistently for at least cheap enough i
would simplify it i think i think
businesses get customers
uh charge them enough where you get to
keep some pr some profit and keep
customers right you got to do those
three things and get customers is
usually the hardest one um and it's the
hardest one in this case so so that's
why i said the founders that have the
right marketing mojo that was the key
part of what i said because you have to
have a tr a way that you're gonna like
get traffic for this and over time i
think they will
out-compete their
old-school alternatives because they're
outdated now so here's my
other
that 50
that goes to creators you could maybe
spend on acquiring customers
exactly
and um and you can give away a lot of
the content for free initially right
because of that so here's my hack for
for this this is also a hustle this is
maybe my big co side hustle this is
you're a pm at google or you're a
product manager at duckduckgo and you're
a search engine
well the search engines have one way
that they cheat which is when you search
for something they can just give you
their result as the top result always
right that's like google with their one
box thing if you just say hey what's the
best holiday they
surface the best results in a box so you
don't even need to click and go to a
website or if you go to google images
and you search for icon of this or stock
photo or royalty free whatever they
could just serve you the google results
for this and they have all the ai talent
in the world to do this and this could
become a product line that generates you
know nine figures a year for these
companies so if you want to you know if
you're inside one of these big companies
that's another pitch you can make to
your boss that says hey boss how does
this sound we use our ai talent on
something that we're already getting
millions of searches for a year and it
will generate you know 100 million
dollars plus in revenue within three
years can i work on that project and
then the answer will be uh yes and why
haven't i promoted you already dude i
went so i've got two stories i went to a
conference and i met this woman who
was she was part of the crew that
managed this so basically google makes
95 of their revenue from one thing but
they're constantly trying to launch all
this other stuff so they've probably
done stuff that you don't even know
exists um but and they'll like buy stuff
and try to run it and make it bigger
like in it one example is zagat you
remember zagat
yeah the restaurant reviews is that
right yeah google owned it a lot of
people didn't don't even know that but
google owned it and i talked to this
woman whose job it was to help manage
the ceos of the projects and decide
what's interesting and what's not and
she told me that they have some products
that would scale to a hundred million in
revenue in only a couple years and they
would kill it and i was like why'd you
kill it and they go well two reasons one
the people who we get to run them
they're oftentimes paid so much money
that they don't give a like if
you're just like running your own
startup you're like this has to work
because this is where 95 of my net worth
is like i would be screwed whereas the
people who work at google they're like
dude i make so much money each year i
don't really want this to succeed that
much i have to work more and still get
paid some and so she told me that and
second they're like google is so big
that even though a product makes a
hundred million plus in revenue over the
course of a few years which could be
worth a couple billion dollars it's just
not worth it to us we just have so much
better ways to spend our time and i was
flabbergasted and i knew this other
woman who ran this one thing that was
doing over 100 million in revenue and
they killed it because they're like this
just isn't big or interesting enough and
it's just it's pretty wild to think
about that
yeah it's insane actually i did this
when we got acquired by twitch i had in
one of the meetings i had with emmett i
was
who's the ceo i was talking about like
oh yeah if we try like this could
actually make this much
and i noticed he didn't like react in
any way like when i say something that i
think you're gonna get excited about you
don't get excited i'm like hey
i thought you would
i thought that would like register for
you it looks like it didn't tell me why
that didn't um
and he was just like
he's basically like look uh
we make this much revenue over here so
to move the needle on revenue you have
to be like the size of the price has to
be x
and like trying to make revenue brings
in all this like legal complexity
business ops complexity and like
potentially stands in the way of user
growth and so like we either want
something that hits this threshold on
revenue or make it free and just
optimize for user growth i was like oh
okay so like not interested in like you
know
this kind of like eight figures plus you
know uh of of revenue a year it's like
no
um and i was like and i i didn't take it
i was like thank you for teaching me
that because yeah that makes sense my
startup brand was wired where that's a
big number but now that i'm at a big
company i need to like rewire it as a
small number dude when we sold to
hubspot we went we sold in uh i forget
like
mid to late january and so we went into
the year 2021 with many many millions of
dollars of advertising revenue booked
and contracts signed and everything and
this year we you know we would have made
many eight figures in revenue and
when they sold when we sold they go um
look we make this much money i think
what's hubspot make a year like 1.2
billion a year in revenue and it's
growing quick they're like your little
20 million dollars it doesn't really
matter to us we rather you not focus on
that so
we gave all the money back like we yeah
we had to call them and we had to be
like hey
this company i know that you booked like
five hundred thousand dollars in
advertising sorry we can't do it anymore
and
we gave it back and it i was heartbroken
i was like oh you're killing me and they
just didn't and they're right i mean
it's smart but it was crazy to think
about that
dude uh
okay i want you to just don't type hands
up hands in the air
guess google's
revenue last quarter
i would imagine that they do
uh
i don't know
30 40 billion dollars a year
okay 34 billion a year so let's divide
by four and let's just say round number
10 10 billion a quarter good guess
that's actually what i would have
guessed they did 61 billion dollars last
quarter
so four times that is what
24 240
we don't do public math yes
dude what
unless i'm looking at something that's
wrong but uh i'm looking on statistics
right now it's it came up in my in the
first google search and i was like no
right that's annual not quarterly and
then i looked at another place and says
it's second quarter revenue of 2021 was
61 billion dollars okay now
how long have you felt like google's a
juggernaut like an absolute juggernaut
that's already like pete it's already
like at the peak of its powers since the
beginning of years ago yeah
how many years ago did you feel that way
like let's just say like
at what point in time if i was like hey
google's revenue is already like you
know just absolutely monstrous not too
much upside left like five years ago
would you have said that
uh yeah so like in 2015 which was six
years ago now if you told me just to
like invest all my money into google i'd
be like why would you why would you what
why would you ever want something that's
already so big it's not going to grow
that much
yeah so since that date
that same quarter in 20 2015
uh this quarter was three and a half
times revenue
times more revenue so it went from 17
billion to 61 billion in that five-year
span when i think of that so there's
like i used to be all about facebook i
actually think that if you told me
this could be like crazy wrong in 10
years if facebook and google
are not like i think they'll exist but
if they're not like the big shots i
actually i'll be surprised if they're
still the big shots
would you agree
so
that could mean many things is it like
there's the big shot like microsoft is
still a big shot but and it was always a
big shot but like facebook and google
kind of like
took all their shine for like a decade
plus
um you know as microsoft was either flat
or kind of declining but it was still
big but it didn't have the talent it
wasn't growing as fast stocks not
appreciating as fast so is it that where
it kind of stagnates or you're like it's
actually going to go down
i think it's going to go down and here's
why have you ever met anyone that worked
at google or facebook
yes
um like they currently work there
yes i think that google so google is
interesting
point one is that it kind of succeeds in
spite of itself they basically invented
this one thing that hasn't changed that
significantly and it's always been
amazing okay so they kind of have that
going which is good but the second thing
that they have is that
people i don't think particularly like
working there like it's not cool i think
to say you work at google is like five
years ago saying you worked at goldman
it's not really that particularly
interesting and i also think that the
people who work there unlike goldman
whereas goldman will explicitly say
we're going to work your we're
going to work you down to the bone
you're going to grind and most of you
aren't going to work here in five years
google's the opposite they say we care
about you we do this we do that right
and can i fold your laundry can i do
would you like a foot massage while you
are you program you know this code right
now and because they do that they create
entitled babies who protest and get
angry uh when anything bad happens for
example i think last year there was this
big event and i don't actually know what
happened i don't know the reason it
could have been justified who knows but
they had a walkout so a lot of the
employees just like walked out for the
day and uh when i saw that i was like oh
this is like the beginning of the end
because if you think about google do
they do things that maybe you could
describe as evil or you don't agree with
definitely yes but as an employee are
they overwhelmingly like a soft place to
work that you get paid significant
amounts of money barely have to show up
and they pretty much are like oh yes
honey like you need anything of course
they are and if people are willing to
protest that and walk out then they're
soft and they're going they're going to
die soon that's why i think that
they're going to die soon
rant's gone wrong there's like a there's
like a phrase what's it it's uh uh
hard time uh hard times
no difficult times make strong men
strong men make easy times easy times
make soft men that and that's like
what's going on right now at google so
that's why i wouldn't be surprised if
they don't exist i i had a friend who
worked at facebook and they would send
me there's an internal uh facebook group
for employees
and it's basically just a session
where they just vent and about
everything that's happening inside the
company
and he would send me screenshots
of what the topic would be and it'd be
like
the most petty
trivial like hey i noticed that the
orange juice has moved in the cafeteria
like
you know i like to eat salads and when
it was by the salad bar it just really
complemented my healthy lifestyle and
now that it's over by the meat i feel
like i've been vegan for two years and
now that it's by the meat it's like a
micro aggression against my vegan it's
like dude these people were complaining
about the dumbest stuff and they would
have hundreds and hundreds of comments
which means just hours wasted fighting
in the facebook comments amongst
facebook employees
and it was everything from the parking
garage layout to the milk choices to the
the wording and the email that was sent
out to listen to the softness of the
song so for the longest time and i think
he still does it but when my wife worked
there he was definitely doing it zuck
and cheryl sandberg but i think for sure
zuck or definitely for sure suck it was
either every friday or one friday a
month i forget
zuck would do in all hands and you could
show up in person and you could ask him
a question
and it was mostly empty like you know
facebook at the time had 15 000
employees and like 100 people would be
there and to me that's crazy right
that's like imagine like going back uh
years and years and like you get to ask
andrew carnegie or john rockefeller like
any question or henry ford like any
question like that's it's like pretty
amazing i'd be there every friday and i
used to tell my wife i'm like man if you
keep asking interesting questions he's
gonna get to know you but he'll be like
you know sarah that's a great idea come
and talk to me i was like you gotta just
be there every time and
one time
i heard the story about this person he
raised his hand and uh they're like uh
yeah what's your question he goes look
we have a huge problem at facebook um
we don't have tampons in the men's
restroom and it's like
discriminatory and zuck was like he said
like
is this really what you want to spend
your time discussing or can we discuss
this out there and they're like like we
have to talk about he's like all right
head of hr or how to please come up here
and like address this and uh i swear i
heard the story of that someone asked
that during the their time would suck
is that crazy
i feel like we should end on this
just like a man it's like just is that
really what five minutes
is a better look than current google
employee
totally isn't that amazing it's a such a
stronger signal that your ex google than
current google
i completely agree do you agree with me
do you think that they're gonna go down
no i think they're kind of juggernauts
but i do think like
every
they become less and less relevant over
time i think they've i think facebook
particularly has done an amazing job
fighting off irrelevancy
um like tooth and nail i think zuck
knows and therefore
like is he goes to war for it but they
just have all the there's the natural
like father time is undefeated or
whatever like basically over time
there's a natural decline and then
there's a talent drop off as for people
that are going to go work there versus
go work at new exciting high upside
things
and then there's the like um you know
like anti big tech company backlash
where now if there's a if there's a new
social network that takes off like
instagram did or like um whatsapp was
doing facebook can't buy it anymore so
the next one that takes off facebook
can't buy
and uh that will because of antitrust
and so they're just gonna lose their
stranglehold because that was their
previous way of like extending their
lifespan was to acquire the next best
social thing and bring it in to bring it
in house so that's gone for all the tech
companies they can't do that anymore
i typically hate discussing big company
like google and facebook i find to
be incredibly boring and i'm like who
the cares like this doesn't
actually impact me at all and i think
that takes place or that exists for a
lot of our listeners so i'll be very
curious to hear if they even remotely
cared about this discussion uh so
let's see let's see what they have to
say
yeah tweet at us all right i'm out of
here we're done
[Music]
never looking back